the meeting was brokered after chairman
Nunez issued a subpoena April 30th for
records of an alleged government
surveillance abuse during the 2016
election Chairman Nunez and Gowdy met
with the Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein as well as FBI and
intelligence officials a source familiar
with the matter said the classified
records there relate to an individual
intelligence source are as significant
as the dossier used by the FBI and
Justice Department to secure a
surveillance warrant for Trump campaign
aide the dossier was DNC and Clinton
campaign funded opposition research the
chairmen have the house speakers backing
it's completely within the scope of the
investigation that's been ongoing for a
while with respect to FISA I actually
think that this is something that
probably should have been answered a
while ago in a statement after the
meeting the Chairman said the dialogue
will continue next week
adjust the Department spokeswoman said
they welcome the opportunity to work on
a resolution and accommodate the records
request Brett and on those Michael Cohen
records there are more legal maneuvers
with with the bank records well that's
right in court filings Cohen's legal
team says some records belong to other
Michael Cohen's they accused the lawyer
Michael avenatti of making quote
numerous incorrect statements to the
public in an apparent attempt to
prejudice and discredit mr. Cohen mr.
Alvarez conduct and somehow obtaining
random bank records and publishing them
without proper concern for their
accuracy is extremely troubling for the
parties in this case the court and the
public on Twitter avenatti responded
that the cohen court filings are
baseless and he accuses Cohen's team of
conceding the receipt of a half million
dollars from those with Russian ties the
company involved said it solely owned
and controlled by Americans meantime the
Treasury Department's inspector general
is conducting an inquiry into whether
Michael Cohen's confidential banking
records were elite Bret will continue to
follow all sides of that cast thank you